okay welcome back everybody so I think
the midterm exam is due today at 5:00
p.m. most of you have already handed it
in if you have not handed it in please
either email it to us or submit it on
the catalyst Dropbox or slide it under
my door by 5:00 p.m. today okay how many
in the room have actually taken the exam
so far how many have not taken it okay
just curious okay so remember last time
we were talking about numerical
differentiation of functions or data so
I just want to put this up from last
time we had a couple of different ways
of approximating the derivative okay so
this is finite difference approximations
to f prime of x it's kind of an X okay
so what were my approximations that we
had from last last lecture for
difference backward difference and
central difference okay so forward
difference was f prime X is
approximately equal to f of X plus Delta
X minus f of X divided by Delta X okay
backward difference was f prime is
approximately equal to f of X minus f of
X minus Delta X divided by Delta X and
central is f prime of X is what
okay plus Delta X so I take so I'm I
think in my point F X in the center of X
plus Delta X and X minus Delta X and I
take the difference and divide by two
Delta X ok is there anything missing
from these expressions the error okay so
this is really important to know we're
going to be picking finite size Delta
X's right we can't take Delta X goes to
zero like we'd want to and so these have
different errors depending on what the
method is okay so what are the method
what's the error for forward difference
sorry ladder order for forward
difference just don't ask order Delta X
backward difference is also also ordered
Delta X and central differences order
Delta x squared so which one of these is
going to be the most accurate method
central central difference right because
if I make Delta X smaller this error
gets way way smaller right it gets
smaller like Delta x squared you know if
I could I'd like to cook up something
that had order Delta X to the fourth or
sixth or eighth that would be even
better right I would have even better
scaling properties okay any questions
about this at this point so on the next
homework I'm going to for example ask
you to cook up a second order accurate
forward difference scheme so what what
types of data would you need to have a
second order accurate forward difference
so for a first order accurate this is
called first-order consulta X's for the
first power this is second-order because
it's to the second power if I wanted a
second order accurate forward different
scheme I would need F evaluated at what
points
okay so second order forward difference
so I think I heard this I would still
need F of X I would still need F of X
plus Delta X but remember I'm plugging
in the Taylor series for these
expressions that I'm trying to cancel as
many terms as I can and to cancel more
and more terms I need additional data
points
I also need f of X plus 2 Delta X ok so
if I give you these three data points
you should be able to cook up a second
order accurate forward difference scheme
and you should be able to show why it's
second-order accurate and you show why
it's second-order accurate by literally
competing the Taylor series of these two
expressions plugging it into whatever
formula you cook up and showing that you
get the thing you want the first
derivative plus terms that are on the
order of Delta x squared ok so this is
going to be like a homework 4 type
problem okay so homework 4 should come
out like tomorrow morning sometime ok
good
in the alright one more point when we
actually have data so in the last
lecture we cooked up data based on a
sine function right we took signing of X
and we computed all three of these
derivatives but in real life if I'm
getting data you know streaming in time
I can't compute the forward difference
and I can't compute the central
difference because I don't have future
points in time right so let's say that I
have a vector of data instead of a
function ok so I have data x1 x2 x3 dot
dot dot up to X n ok these are kind of
my x-values and for now let's just
assume that these are all spaced Delta X
apart but they don't have to be spaced
Delta X apart that's just an assumption
to make this a little easier and let's
say that I have
function over these values so I have F
versus X and that means that I have F
defined at all of these locations okay
so this is you know F 1 F 2 F 3 dot F N
and we have this relationship that F you
know K equals our function of XK and
that equals our function of K Delta X
right so here this subscript K really
means you know if all of our Delta X's
if all of our points are spaced Delta X
apart you know if X 0 is 0 then XK is
just K of these Delta X's away ok so XK
is just K Delta X's 4 evenly spaced data
and so the way I like to think about
this is I just have these two vectors of
data my boss emails me vectors of data
and wants the derivative taken ok my
second vector is the function value at
all of these points so I just have these
two vectors of data I don't have
functions I have my function evaluated
at a discrete set of points so now I'm
gonna ask how do i compute the
derivative based on these vectors how do
i compute DF DX
what's the best scheme I can use to
compute this derivative that we've
derived so far central difference okay
so I'm gonna try to use the central
difference formula right I'm gonna take
so like F prime K the case F prime is
gonna be F k plus 1 minus F K minus 1
divided by 2 Delta X seems fine right I
want like my case value here I just
looked to the left and to the right of
it and I use central difference on those
points but what's the problem with using
the central difference on these vectors
yeah there's a problem applying the
central difference to the first point
and to the last point right so for all
of the middle points I can do central
difference because I have a point to the
left and a point to the right of them
but on the the left most data point and
on the right most data point I don't
have F of 0 and I don't have F of n plus
1 I just am missing these data points ok
so I can do central difference on the
interior points and I have to do
forward and backward on the endpoints so
which one do i do on which so I do
forward on the leftmost point on the
first point and I do backward on the
last point and after this next homework
you're going to have more accurate
formulas for the forward and backward
difference so we can still have second
order accurate schemes for the first and
the last points this makes sense right
so we just can't do central difference
on the endpoints because we don't have
points before and after okay this is
just a practicality of real data
any questions about this so far
okay so the next step is to code this up
let's say that my exes are not spaced
evenly this is a lot nicer if my exes
are spaced evenly delta-x apart then
this formula becomes simple what is my
central difference look like if my exes
are not evenly spaced so if I'll let you
think while I write this up
if exes are not evenly spaced and then
the central difference looks like what F
K prime equals okay so the top stays the
same right because those data points are
just called FK plus 1 and FK minus 1 now
how does the bottom change right so if
these Delta X's can change kind of
variably then really what I need to do
is figure out what this effective Delta
X is between them which is just X you
know in the K in this case it'll be X 3
minus X 1 or X K plus 1 minus XK minus 1
okay so we don't need our Delta X's to
be evenly spaced we just need to know
what the X points are what points our
function is evaluated at also ok
oftentimes real world data doesn't have
uniform spacing in X either okay okay so
let's code this up in MATLAB and see how
it works on data
okay let's see so I have this very
similar example to the one we did last
time so what we're going to do is define
x equals 0.1 0.1 in increments of 0.1 to
3 okay and F is equal to sine of X and
now at this point for all intents and
purposes I can can I can treat these as
vectors of data that I've been handed on
a thumb drive err in an email we know
that it that this data has come from a
real function called sine of X but for
everything that follows below we're just
going to treat X as a vector and F is a
vector just like we did on the right
board okay so I'm just cooking up data
and we're gonna see what we would do if
we just got this data okay so let's just
plot X and F in black and we'll hold on
and I also want to plot X by F in red
X's so here we actually see these red
X's are the data points that we've been
given okay these red X's are the points
in the vector of the x and f points and
the black curve is the true function
that these points have been sampled from
right so I have some experiment or some
simulation and it's following this true
black curve and at every finite Delta X
it's giving me one of these red X data
points okay so the first thing we're
gonna do is maybe your boss tells you
that all of the points in X are evenly
spaced or you do some tests on this X
vector and you find out that all of them
are evenly spaced so you can define a DX
because your formulas going to be a
little bit simpler with a fixed DX this
is our Delta X we're gonna say n is the
length of our data we have n
datapoints okay and I'm going to create
a vector DF DX and initially I'm just
gonna fill it with zeros I'm gonna make
a column vector for DF DX full of zeros
and I'm just gonna go in and fill this
in using our formula there's any
questions please
you know interrupt so this is how we're
really going to illustrate these
concepts is in MATLAB so if you have any
questions please do ask okay so what do
we do to compute the first DF DX the the
leftmost derivative the derivative at X
1 for our difference okay so DF DX at 1
the first value is equal to and how do i
do my forward difference okay so k
equals 1 here so it's f of 2 minus f of
1 divided by DX all right f is a vector
of data so f of 2 minus f of 1 is the
same as f of X plus Delta X minus f of X
where x equals x 1 okay for all of these
central points for all of the interior
points we're going to use central
difference so I'm going to say for I
equals 2 to n minus 1
we're going to do a central difference
DF DX of that index I is gonna equal
okay so what's my central difference for
the 8th data point so f of I plus 1
minus I minus 1 divided by 2 DX okay
and then for the last point we're going
to use a backward difference scheme so
df/dx of the enth data point is going to
be F of n minus F of n minus 1 divided
by DX ok ok so now I'm going to make a
new figure and I'm going to plot the
true solution which is cosine in black
and I'm going to plot our approximation
DF DX in red X's okay and here we go
so this is the true derivative this nice
black cosine curve and all of these red
X's are our approximations and it's a
little more accurate in the middle
because we're doing central differencing
in the middle which is a more accurate
scheme
any questions yeah how many of you have
done this before computed derivatives of
data on a computer how many of you have
never done this before okay good let's
do something else let's add some noise
to this so down here after I defined the
length of F I'm going to say F equals F
plus R and n this is a normally
distributed Gaussian random variable of
the same size as F that one's really
cool you can do really really really
easy stuff like this you can say I want
a vector of Rands of random numbers and
I want that vector to be the same size
as my F vector super simple but I don't
want it to be this will give me a unit
variance random numbers so they're gonna
be like really big numbers unit variance
so I'm going to make it point O one
times R and n ok so I have F plus a
little bit of white noise on top of it
kind of 1%
white noise why don't I just do this up
here so we can see what it looks like ok
so now you see these you know this is my
I messed up let me let me make this
figure nicer so I really want to plot
sine of X and then I want to plot the
true data points okay so you see this
black curve here is the true sign and my
red dots have some error so they're not
perfectly on this black curve ok and now
when I run them through my derivative
function I find that I actually have
errors in all of my derivatives like all
of these red values have error but they
follow this general trend of capturing
the cosine so first of all which of
these two plots looks worse the first
one in the second one do my red points
agree better or worse
first for the second plot okay so the
red points are better in the first plot
worse than the second plot why what does
that mean sorry I wouldn't even say
squaring the error
I'm taking my error and I'm dividing it
by DX which is a small number right so
these are getting multiplied by about a
factor of 10 because my DX is 0.1 so if
you look at these errors are about a
tenth as big as these errors it's really
more like a factor of five but but
that's bad right so differentiation
magnifies errors right so if you had
position data and you were trying to
compute accelerations from that you'd be
in really really bad shape because you'd
be taking two derivatives and so you'd
be multiplying all of your errors by two
DX by you'd be dividing by DX twice it's
bad news okay so something to be aware
of you have to have clean data if you're
going to numerically take the derivative
or you have to take your red x's and do
a numerical smoothing first okay so
later on when we talk about data methods
we'll talk a little bit about kind of
curve fitting and smoothing functions
and getting splines and things like that
but if you just have noisy data and you
take the derivative bad things happen
okay all right I think that's it for
this example
unless there's any questions about the
code yeah so if I need to find line 15
of the code I could just let's comment
this out and I could just add in X of 2
minus X of 1 I could add in X of I plus
1 minus X of I minus 1 I'm not sure I
defined an X did I I think I did and
then X of n minus X of n minus 1 so I
just repeat everything I have for the
F's but for the X's right so I can
compute DX here and 2 DX here and DX
here even if those D X's are changing
now okay so this is how you would make
it general a little worried about
running this because I might have broken
something but yeah it runs and it gives
you the same results okay good question
all right so this is actually a really
nice segue into the next thing I want to
tell you about numerical differentiation
and this is one of my favorite kind of
theoretical things you can you can
derive about numerical differentiation
is that when you're doing these
operations in a computer with finite
precision there's a limit to how much
you can minimize the error there's a
limit to how small and how active sorry
there's a limit to how accurate you can
make these numerical derivatives in a
computer so if I had a forward different
scheme and I wanted to make it more
accurate what do I do
reduce tell 2x yeah right it's like
that's the thing we get to change we get
to change Delta X we get to sample this
thing more finally and our answer gets
more accurate right so if I want
arbitrarily accurate answers why can I
just decrease Delta X forever well our
computers not that fast so that's ok
that's a really good point so first
thing is my error scales with Delta X
right so error we have our error scales
like order Delta X but our compute time
scales like order 1 over Delta X right
every single one of these data points I
have to do some computation on it so if
I make Delta X a million times smaller
I'm doing a million times more little
derivatives ok so it's really bad for
computer time but even worse than that
there's a fundamental limit because my
computer can only represent numbers with
like finite accuracy ok can only
represent numbers to so many decimal
places before it like has no more memory
to write numbers ok so most of you
probably know a little bit about
computers some of you probably know a
lot about computers so how many decimal
places of accuracy does a normal
computer keep numbers to like in MATLAB
if I write a number how many decimals is
it actually keeping in base 10 how many
of you know the answer but it's just
aren't saying it
okay so it's about 16 okay so one of the
most common numbers you'll see in
computers is ten to the minus sixteen
okay so this is the number you're always
trying to achieve in numerix right if
your error is on the order of ten to the
minus sixteen it means that you're doing
as well as you can possibly be doing in
a computer unless you do really special
things but normally a double precision
number double precision means that you
have two bytes on the computer to
represent this number two bytes more
than that anyone know how many bytes
four bytes four bytes okay so this
equals four bytes which I guess equals
32 bits yeah and you get I don't think
this is right I think this is 8 bytes
anyway you get 52 binary decimals of
accuracy maybe I'll do a whole lecture
on what your computer is doing at some
point but for now you can basically the
upshot is if I have some number in that
lab if I say 5 plus 10 to the minus 17
MATLAB
really thinks the answer is exactly 5 it
doesn't know how to have a number as big
as 5 plus something as small as 10 to
the minus 17 in the same number it just
can't represent that that number as any
different than 5 so it's answer is
exactly 5.000 dot dot 16 decimals oh
okay
so what this machine precision this is
called we sometimes call it like epsilon
which is machine precision this is the
limit of how close your computer can
tell different numbers of heart
you type 1 plus 10 to the minus 17 it
doesn't know that that's different from
1 it can't tell any difference ok so the
idea here is every number that you ever
represent in a computer is going to have
roundoff errors when you write pi it's
gonna spit out a bunch of digits of pi
but it's not exactly pi it's about 10 to
the minus 16 off from the true value of
pi same thing when you write down square
root of 2 or e or any not nice number it
can actually exactly represent numbers
like integers and 1/2 sand things like
that but any weird number like square
root of 2 or e or pi is going to have
this built-in roundoff error because the
computer just can't represent it
perfectly ok so now we're gonna take
this idea of roundoff error and we're
gonna plug it into our finite difference
derivative our forward difference scheme
and we're gonna find that as we decrease
Delta X our approximation gets better
and better and better until it starts
magnifying this roundoff error and then
it'll get worse and worse and worse
ok so let's say DF DT is equal to f of T
plus Delta t minus f of T divided by
delta T ok
but really every number in here has some
error associated with it okay and for
right now I'm going to assume that these
numbers were perfect and it's the
computer that's messing things up so
there's some little epsilon machine
precision on this and this and this okay
now I'll let you work this out but
really the only epsilon that matters is
the one in the numerator because it's
getting divided by delta-t
and so what we have is f of T plus Delta
t minus F of T divided by a delta t plus
error divided by delta T this error is
is machine error okay so there's two
different ways that error can enter into
this calculation one is through this
kind of Taylor series or finite
difference approximation error so this
is equal to F prime plus order delta T
error this is from essentially Taylor
series Plus this epsilon over delta T
error which is from machine precision
does that make sense so far all right
every time you enter a number in MATLAB
there's some little kind of roundoff
fudge error that is introduced in that
step and if Delta T is too small you
actually make that roundoff error
look really big if you divide by a
really small delta T this number starts
getting big okay are there questions
before I move on
okay so so essentially what this looks
like is if I had a plot of error versus
delta T so this is kind of total error
both of these terms right these are both
my error terms the sum of all of my
errors both from the Taylor series
finite difference errors and from this
machine precision errors for if I start
with really really big delta T like the
Delta T's the word using and the
examples are like point one or point O
one those are pretty big compared to ten
to the minus sixteen right like what's
ten to the minus sixteen divided by
point one 10 to the 9 is 15 still super
super small way bigger than order 0.1
okay so for really big delta T most of
my error is coming from this Taylor
series and I start with a big error from
the Taylor series as I decrease delta T
this error gets smaller
while this error starts to get bigger
but this one is so so tiny that for
awhile I actually get much better much
much less error as I make sorry this is
Delta T's smaller this is 1 over delta T
okay so we're making delta T smaller in
this direction okay so as delta T gets
smaller my error gets smaller for a
little while actually for quite awhile
until at some point this error has grown
large enough that it's now the dominant
error in this expression and every time
I decrease delta T this one gets bigger
and bigger and bigger until it
eventually starts to dominate so there's
really this kind of optimal delta T that
really does minimize this error
okay
if you compute this I'm not going to go
through the details but you can actually
do this from the lecture notes you can
take this error expression and you can
take partial error because errors a
function of Delta te right I can take
partial of that with respect to delta T
and I can set it equal to zero and I can
actually find V delta T where I have
zero slope in the error my minimum error
as a function of delta T and for a
forward different scheme it turns out to
be about delta T equals 10 to the minus
5 and that's because these terms really
have some constants out front that we
can kind of characterize but so this is
about 10 to the minus 5 so if you're
doing forward difference you can't
really do that much better than 10 to
the minus 5 or 10 to the minus 6 for
delta T and if you try things will start
getting worse and now you know why okay
other schemes are better if I had a
central different scheme than I might be
able to go much lower in error and for a
much smaller Delta T so other schemes
you can get lower error just because
this starts off being much smaller okay
that's all I really want to say about
finite difference differentiation unless
there are questions this is really
important stuff this is going to be so
this is not just if my boss emails me a
vector of data and tells me to take the
derivative which happens more often than
you would think these basic formulas
approximating derivatives and in the
next section we'll see approximating
integrals are going to be the basis for
how we numerically integrate Odie's okay
so what I'm going to see what we're
gonna see soon is that we have OD e's
like
df/dt sorry let's say dxdt equals some
nasty function f of X number this is
what we've been doing for the last few
weeks we have some ordinary differential
equation where X is some trajectory in
time that satisfies this equation
maybe it's the population dynamics of
bunnies or radioactive decay or the
motion of a spring on a mass but in a
computer I'm going to have to use some
approximation for DX DT so if I use
forward difference I would say okay well
this is really XK plus 1 minus XK
divided by delta T equals F of I'm gonna
have to plug in some real finite value
for X let's say XK okay and so if I take
this to its logical conclusion right I
multiplied both sides by delta T I add
XK and I get this expression XK plus 1
equals XK my current States so my future
state is my current state plus delta T
times F of my current state we just
wrote an integrator this will integrate
your ordinary differential equation you
give it X naught I can give you X 1 now
you have X 1 I can give you X 2 now you
have X 2 I can give you X 3 this is an
iteration that steps your differential
equation forward in time this is called
an integrator okay we have just
integrated this differential equation
and found an approximate vector X which
represents the trajectory of X in time
this has error associated with it
because this has error associated with
it so every time step we're picking up
error and that's a bad thing okay so you
know on Friday and in the next week
we're going to be talking about these
types of problems these integration
problems so it's really important that
we
and these basic finite-difference
derivatives where the errors come from
and and what these things look like in a
computer okay before we do this I want
to show you how to do numerical
integration of data okay we just took
the derivative now we're going to
integrate we're going to add up f of X
and we'll probably get through about
half of this today and the other half on
Friday and then on Friday we'll kind of
go farther with this numerical
integration of Odie's
ok ok so this should be kind of maybe a
little bit of a simpler week than before
because before we were dealing with like
you know nasty ordinary differential
equations and phase portraits and
geometry this week we're doing calculus
right we all know how to integrate
functions and differentiate functions
and this is like pretty familiar to us
so if I have some function f versus X
what are some ways that I can compute
the area of this the integral of F with
respect to X what's the way we learn in
like a calculus class
so yeah you can add up little little
bars little rectangles right I can chop
this up into a bunch of DX's and add the
height in the area of those rectangles
there are some other interesting ways I
think Archimedes did this with triangles
which seems bizarrely difficult to me
I think rectangles is way easier than
triangles but you could do it with
triangles so I could chop this up into a
bunch of rectangles like this and I can
add up the area of all of these
rectangles right this is the Riemann
integral how many of you have heard of
lebesgue integral it turns out that the
Riemann integral we learned in calculus
is not the only only integral this is
kind of a matter of convenience telling
you that there was only one integral but
there's definitely more ways to
integrate this so if I had a nasty nasty
function that had Delta functions if I
had a finite number of Delta functions
in my function this happens sometimes my
Riemann integral is gonna blow up like I
don't know how to handle these Delta
functions using vertical bars I just
don't know how to do it with Riemann
integrals it turns out that there's
something called a lebesgue integral
it's spelled weird it's spelled like
Lebec
but it's called lebesgue and it's called
the layer-cake integral so instead of
integrating with vertical bars you
integrate with horizontal bars and you
take the limit as Delta X goes to zero
and it's much easier for handling these
finite discontinuities in your in your
function okay not something you need to
know about but in general you should
know that there are other types of
integrals and you could formulate this
in other ways and there's like a whole
very important theory of probability
built on lebesgue measures instead of
riemann measures ways of measuring area
okay so our integral of F with respect
to X so f of X DX we're going to give it
some limits of integration we're going
to integrate from A to B
okay so I'm gonna write down this
formula it's always a pain to derive it
you know on the spot so I'm gonna write
it down so essentially what we're doing
is we're gonna take the limit as these
rectangles become very very small which
is the same as saying I'm taking the
limit as my number of rectangles
approaches infinity okay n is the number
of divisions or rectangles that I'm
going to put in here and this is the sum
of all of my rectangle areas so for K
equals 1 to N I'm gonna add up all of my
rectangles and the rectangle height is
just F at that value X so f of a plus B
minus a divided by n times K so the case
rectangle has a height of F of that X
and that X is a plus B minus a divided
by n times K think of this as my little
Delta X B minus a divided by n is Delta
X so this is the height this is you know
Delta X and then I take this height and
I multiply it by the width
what's my width of one rectangle right
it's my Delta X that's B minus a divided
by n ok so this is this is my kind of
formula my Riemann integral I could do
this take the limit as n goes to
infinity I have infinitely many
rectangles this Delta X goes to 0
because I'm dividing by something that's
going to infinity and this is my Riemann
integral but just like we did in finite
difference derivatives we're going to
stop here and we're going to have a
finite number of rectangles
we're not going to take the limit as n
goes to infinity we're not going to make
these Delta axes go to zero we're really
going to add up finitely many in
rectangles because that's what we can do
in a computer so this is approximately
equal to this for a finite
so what I've done here is actually a
right-sided rectangle rule integral this
is a little bit of a esoteric it's
actually kind of practical so I could
define the height of my rectangle using
the left point of that interval or the
right point of that integral so I could
use this height or I could have used
that height and this function up here is
using the right most point of my
rectangle to get the height I could also
use the leftmost point like I've drawn
here okay so this is really a
right-sided rectangle formula and if I
wanted the left
dot-dot-dot the left-handed rectangle
formula it would be this limit I'll get
to that later you could get another
expression for it I don't love this
formula because it's really nasty and
complicated okay there's a lot of moving
parts a lot of terms they don't like
this formula it's too complicated so
let's make it way way simpler in terms
of you know vectors of data so let's
give these things names so what I really
want to think about is this is some X 0
X 1 X 2 dot dot dot up to X n ok and
this point is f of X 0 we're going to
call that f 0 f of X 1 is f 1 this is
just like we did for the finite
difference derivative we're just going
to call these X 0 to X ends and these F
zeros to F ends and now our integral
becomes way way simpler
so now we have the limit as Delta X goes
to 0 of the sum from k equals 1 to n of
f of X K Delta X much simpler and again
for numerical calculus we just get rid
of this limit and we have a finite Delta
X if my Delta X's were variable I would
just have XK minus XK minus 1 that's my
variable Delta X ok so n is the number
of rectangles Delta X is the spacing
kind of the width of all of those
rectangles and this is the height of
kind of the right side of these
rectangles any questions about this
formulation so far it's a little messier
than the derivative but when you write
it like this that's actually pretty
simple right so what we're gonna do in
the next lecture is we're actually going
to approximate how different this
expression is sorry let's get rid of
this because we're going to do this in a
computer we're gonna see how different
this approximate numerical integral is
to the true actual integral again using
Taylor series and getting orders of
error in terms of Delta X's and things
like that so we're gonna get the same
types of formulas for what type of error
our integrals have using Taylor series
and then we're going to learn how to
like code this up in MATLAB and cook up
a couple of better integrals the left
and the right rectangle rules stink so
we'll have much much better integral
formulas kind of later in the next class
ok that's all for today I'll see you
again on Friday and then next week we'll
do o de integration
you